- Hey guys, it's Justine
and WWDC 2021 is here.
If you guys watched the event,
you're probably already
aware of all of the things
that I'm gonna talk about.
But if you didn't, we're gonna
go through a little recap.
Now WWDC is a developer conference,
which is mostly focusing around software
and giving developers a heads-up of like,
"Hey, this is what we have coming out,
start developing for our platform."
It is exciting 'cause if you
do have a developer's account
and you are a developer,
you will have access to beta
versions of these things.
So, I'm just patiently waiting
here for the iOS 15 beta,
the new iPad OS, and of
course, Mac OS Monterey!
That is the followup
to our current Big Sur.
And I've loved Big Sur so much.
I know I talked about this
in my Predictions Video.
And it's crazy 'cause my
sister and I were discussing
what we thought the name was gonna be.
And I don't know, we kind of guessed it.
Monterey. I like Monterrey.
Man, we've never been to Mammoth.
- [Sister] Maybe Tahoe?
But that's in Nevada, but also California.
- Mac OS Monterrey, oh!
Let's start with some of the
things that they announced.
Obviously, iOS 15 is something
that we're all looking forward to.
Because this is setting us up
for what to expect in the
next version of the iPhone.
So the iPhone 13,
or whatever it is that
they're gonna be calling it,
will of course be launching with iOS 15.
And the first thing that they talked about
in the keynote was FaceTime.
And I'm kind of excited about
this because I like FaceTime,
but there's so many things,
especially over this past year,
that we've come so accustomed
to being able to do
in video conferencing.
And of course that's being
able to share a link out
and anybody being able to view it,
whether you're on an
Android, or a Mac, or a PC.
And even be able to share
what's on your screen.
There'll be so many times
that you're doing a FaceTime
and you have to click off.
You wanna share a link,
you send it in iMessages.
But now you can actually
do FaceTime screen-sharing
which is really cool.
They also wanted FaceTime audio
to be a little bit more
natural and conversational,
so they announced Spacial
Audio and Voice Isolation.
And they also have the option of switching
from voice isolation to wide spectrum.
And with that, that'll pick up
all of the sound around you.
With voice isolation,
that's just gonna be doing
just that: isolating your voice
(chuckles) and just ignoring
the sounds around you.
They have a new grid layout
which will highlight
anytime anybody is talking,
which is nice, also very common,
so I'm glad that they are
bringing that to FaceTime.
Portrait Mode Video,
having that beautiful BOCA,
which this is a beautiful BOCA
because I'm using a very expensive camera
and a very expensive 1.4 F-stop lens.
But with portrait mode
and being able to use the
LIDAR and depth sensing,
you're able to mimic this sort of a look.
So I think that's gonna
be really cool to do
in your FaceTime videos.
But the one thing that
I'm so excited about
is FaceTime links.
So you're gonna be able to
schedule your FaceTime calls
and send out a link to
your friends, or family,
or whoever it is that you're
gonna be chatting with.
And it doesn't matter
if they're on Android
or if they want to do the
FaceTime chat on their PC,
in a browser, like this is huge.
The fact that Apple was opening this up
to just like not just Apple.
Pretty excited about that.
I feel like they're gonna be targeting
that work from home environment.
I wish that they would have had this
about a year-and-a-half ago.
But hey, I'm here for it.
We're all here for it.
And I think it's gonna make a
lot of these conference calls
so much more seamless.
SharePlay is another really
cool new feature at FaceTime,
where you're gonna be able to
listen to music, watch movies,
TV shows, all together.
And then you're gonna
be able to use AirPlay
to actually take whatever
that high quality content is
and share it to your TV.
So not only will you be
able to be FaceTiming
and watching this content simultaneously,
but you'll be able to
transfer it to your TV
and be able to watch it in
a higher-quality fashion.
I've actually never
watched content like this
with anybody else, but I think
it'll be cool to try it out.
I'm very excited about some
of the iMessage updates.
I love this new collage design.
This is gonna give you an
all new way to share content.
I feel like anytime I'm out
with my friends or my family
and we're at an event,
we're always sharing pictures
and photos from that.
So what's gonna be cool,
is you're gonna be able to
have all of those photos
in this little collage view.
And now they're gonna be having this thing
where you can actually have
these photos automatically
be added to your library.
So you're not gonna have to
save them all individually,
it'll automatically be added.
And this is what they're calling
the "Shared with you," with you section.
So not only will this be in photos
but it'll also be available in music.
And you'll get a list of all of the links
that people have shared with you.
And this is seriously so cool,
because I use iMessage so
much for this type of thing.
Not only for food
recommendations for restaurants,
but news articles or very
important things that I'm like,
"You sent me this, but
where the heck is it?"
They have an updated notification summary
with various graphics and memojis.
But this is something that's cool:
They have this new Focus Mode.
So if you are in focus, Work Mode,
you will only receive notifications
from your co-workers
or Slack notifications.
So you're able to dictate
what mode you're in.
So if you're at home
you can maybe get notifications
from your friends or family
but not get co-worker notifications.
I love this kind of separation
from work and home life,
but I, unfortunately I
don't really have that.
It all just blends into one.
It's like, "Oh, did you
want to have a weekend?"
"What's a weekend?"
"We don't really have those."
We have some new intelligent
features like LiveText.
So if you take a photo of a whiteboard
that will automatically
be translated into text.
So you can basically copy
and paste that whiteboard
and paste that as text into an email.
It's also taking all of the
texts in all of these photos
and making everything searchable.
They've updated the new photo memories:
You can choose different songs
and it'll re-edit those little
AI edited movies for you.
I think that this is a very easy thing;
If there's a face that
you no longer want to see
in your or memories,
I feel like you should be able to say,
have check a button that says,
"I never want you to see this face again."
Really? Is that so hard?
All of these incredible features.
Can we please, just get that one
for the sake of many people's
sanity and well-being.
It would be great. I would
love that. Thank you.
There's an update to
Wallet which will allow you
to have access to car keys, hotel keys.
Basically have auto check-in.
You'll pick up your phone and you're like,
"Oh look, there's my room
key, I'm already checked in."
That is something that I'm excited about.
There's just something about confrontation
that I really don't like when
checking into at a hotel.
It's always just like an ordeal.
But I do like checking in
when they give you a free little
snack or a bottle of water.
I think I'd rather just
go straight to my room.
You can put the water in there
and I don't have to see anyone.
Have I mentioned I'm an introvert?
Digital identity is something
that I'm a huge fan of.
I do feel like this is gonna
be the future of identity
and carrying cards.
I think that's a whole nother conversation
to talk about how
important the blockchain is
to be able to allow us to
have this digital identity.
And, do you guys hear that?
Can you hear that or am I just hearing it?
There's a small child
upstairs (table pounds)
stomping her little tiny feet. (giggles)
Anyway, blockchain technology,
merging that with digital identity,
I think is gonna be really
huge in the upcoming years.
But they are doing a little first leap
into that with us here having the ability
to scan our driver's licenses
and be able to potentially
use this at TSA.
I hope that they make it easy
to update your driver's
license with the DMV,
because that place is,
it's yeah, I don't like it.
They've got a new design
for the Weather app.
There's some new graphics to
better understand conditions
like the wind UV barometric pressure.
I mean, I really just usually say,
"Hey Siri, what's the weather,"
and then she tells me.
AirPods is something that
I was so excited about.
I was hoping, just fingers crossed,
that they maybe were gonna
announce some new air pods.
I just love the first
edition of the AirPods.
These are still my absolute favorite.
But they did announce a new little feature
that will be helping people
who are hearing impaired.
It's called a Conversation Boost,
so you can have them in
and it'll be able to
elevate the conversation
that's happening around you.
That's pretty awesome,
because a lot of people just
wear AirPods all the time
to take calls or get notifications
and out we can actually
help you hear more.
So that's pretty cool.
This was also very exciting.
Of course, the AirTags came out
and using the Proximity
Feature with the AirTags,
you're just able to walk around your house
and find your item.
But now they're gonna be
integrating that into the AirPods.
And of course, you'll be
able to play the sound
to try to find them.
But now adding the proximity support
is going to be really cool.
I can never freaking
find my AirPods, ever.
Spatial Audio with the AirPods
Max and the AirPods Pro
is just such an incredible thing.
It's cool because
they're now bringing this
to tvOS and Mac iOS with the M1 Chip,
so that'll be really cool to try.
There's a bunch of new iPad OS updates,
like new widgets on the home screen.
There's a new Find My in Contact Widgets.
There's new game center widgets.
They've also made it easier to reorganize
a lot of your apps.
So the app library,
you're able to relocate
entire pages or hide those,
so that they're no
longer on your homepage.
There's a new Multitasking Menu
and they've made it so much
easier to do split screen.
I do feel like sometimes
for whatever reason
I always try to do split screen on my iPad
and I either do it wrong
or it doesn't look right.
So I love this little demo that they did
to show how easy it is to
start a new split screen.
You can just drag and drop
one of the apps onto another
and it's like, boom, automatic!
There's also updates coming to Notes.
And I'm such a huge Notes fan,
I use this to write all of my scripts.
Right now, I have all of the notes
from the WWDC event written here.
And it's so easy because you can just
share these notes directly.
But they've started adding a
few new things like Mentions,
which can be really great
for me and my sister,
and Tyler also, because
when we do the podcast
we will do all of our notes
inside of the Notes app.
So we'll be able to mention,
"Hey Tyler, do you think
this is a good idea?"
Or, "Hey, Jenna, make sure you do this."
There's also hashtags.
There's also an activity
view so you'll be able to see
the things that have changed.
And I'll even have Quick Notes,
so you'll be able to use your Apple Pencil
and just swipe from the corner
and just start taking notes.
And those will also all be
available right in the Notes app.
I love the Notes app. It's the best.
Obviously privacy is such a huge concern.
I mean, we are sharing
so much of our lives
and personal information
on all of these devices.
So I love that Apple is really
spearheading all of this
to make sure that we are being safe.
So they announced an
update for the Mail app,
which will give us the option
to hide our IP addresses.
'Cause they were talking about
a lot of these spam emails
can tell if you open it,
because they have these
invisible little graphics
and all kinds of things in
them to be able to track you,
to get your IP address,
and then track you all
over the freaking web.
Like, get out of my business!
They've also announced
that there is an iCloud+.
This will be we able to use Safari
to do a private relay browsing.
So this is gonna be adding a
whole nother level of security.
So if you do want to sign up
for some newsletter or something,
you can hide your email.
So you can create endless amounts
of different email addresses,
and then have them forwarded
to your actual email address.
And if you want to delete
one of those email addresses
you can easily do that too.
They also talked about
HomeKit Secure Video.
You can receive, like if
a package or something
is delivered to your door,
you'll get a package notification.
And I was just thinking
of the amount of packages
that I receive on a daily basis;
my phone is just gonna be like,
ding, ding, ding ding, ding.
Just always exciting
when I get a fun package.
But yeah, definitely
want to test that out.
They also announced a new way
to recover your iCloud account
if you're unable to access it.
So you can add trusted people
who will not have access
to your iCloud account,
but they will be an added trusted person
that can call and retrieve
a number or a PIN number,
and then you have to enter that
so that you can get
back into your account.
Along that same note of iCloud recovery,
they added Legacy Accounts.
If someone passes away,
you'll be able to designate
who can have access to your information
and then what to do with it.
And it's really a terrible
thing to think about,
but I'm really, really glad
that they're doing this.
They talked a lot about health
and I love the fact that
Apple is very health focused.
Obviously with the Apple Watch,
this has so many health
features built into it,
but it is surprising how
much has actually built
into the iPhone.
They have this new Walking
Steadiness Feature.
So it will be able to recognize
and determine your walking trends.
And along these sort of same lines,
they've got another new feature
where you're able to share
your health with someone.
This is gonna be very
helpful for I feel like,
if we want our parents to be able
to share their health data with us.
So you get a notification
when one of your parents
may have a lower heart rate
or a higher heart rate.
Or if they're walking steadiness declines
you'll be able to get a notification that,
"Hey, something's going on,
maybe you should check on so-and-so."
Some updates in watch OS:
They have two new workouts.
There's a Pilates and a Tai-Chi workout.
I love that a really been
integrating new workouts
into the Apple Watch.
I still wish that I could
wear this for jujitsu,
but they do have a martial
arts option on here.
They didn't officially announce home OS,
but they were talking a lot about HomeKit.
I feel like this might be
tying into a separate event.
Hopefully there'll be
something really cool
that they announce for the home.
I did think that maybe we would have heard
a little bit more about this,
but they just we're showing
how everything all works together.
Mac OS Monterrey, I cannot
wait to try this out.
I'm very excited about
it because I did just,
ah, Big Sur was so beautiful,
so they're just adding
some updates to this.
Now I use multiple devices
all the time so usually
I will have my main
computer, I'll have my iPad,
and it sometimes I'll even
have my MacBook next to me.
And all of these things, I'm
doing something different,
and they're all still working together.
But now, this is probably
honestly one of the best updates
that I've seen at WWDC so
far, of the whole event.
It's called Universal Control.
So if I have my iPad,
my iMac, and my MacBook
all sitting next to each other,
they will automatically act as, I guess,
like external devices,
but I can use them all
with the same mouse,
the same keyboard.
So I can use my mouse on my iMac
and then I can scroll over to my iPad
and then I can be using
my iPad with my mouse
and I can type and I
can use shortcut keys.
And then I can slide all
the way over to my MacBook
and everything just works seamlessly.
This is freaking cool!
Now I'm just saying it out loud.
This is exciting.
Like super excite, like
I'm hyped about this.
And if you guys aren't hyped about it,
that's fine, it's okay.
Allow me to have this moment.
(inhales)
To know all of this stuff
that we've talked about today
is going to be available to developers,
actually starting today.
One update that I thought was cool
that they mentioned, that I
forgot to mention earlier,
is an update to Apple Maps.
They have this new, I guess
like AR-3D street map view,
where if you're stuck
somewhere and you're lost
you can basically get
your phone, hold it up,
and it'll make this whole
augmented reality map
so it'll show you exactly
where you have to go.
Now I know that Apple Maps,
it's weird because it's like
a love-hate relationship
that I have with it.
Apple Maps looks way
better than Google Maps
and I love that Apple Maps
works with my Apple Watch
so if I'm driving or if I'm on a bike,
it'll give me that haptic feedback
to let me know that I
have a turn coming up.
But for whatever reason,
sometimes I don't feel the confidence
if I have to get somewhere on time,
I usually would go to Google.
But I am excited about
some of these updates
because they've really made
Apple Maps look beautiful.
And to have this
integration in with CarPlay,
it's gonna be cool.
They've added so much more
detail in neighborhoods.
They've redesigned the roads.
They have custom design
landmarks, elevation,
and so much more.
So that was just a little look
at some of the highlights that
were announced here at WWDC.
I love this event because
it really does set us up
for the rest of the year.
And I can not wait to get my
hands on the beta versions
of some of these.
If there's anything that you
would like for me to test out,
please leave it in the comments below.
And with that, I will see
you guys in my next video.
Don't forget to subscribe, hit the bell,
so you'll be notified
when I post a new video.
And now my friends, we are gonna download
some developer software.
See ya later.
(electronic music)